hi today we're looking at fix match
simplifying semi-supervised learning
with consistency and confidence by cukes
on David birth Berthelot and others of
Google research so this paper concerns
semi-supervised learning so what does
semi-supervised learning mean in
semi-supervised learning you have a data
set of labeled samples so right you have
this data set of X's and corresponding Y
labels but this data set sometimes is
very small now you have a much bigger
data set of unlabeled examples just X's
with no labels right so you don't know
what the labels of the of the unlabeled
examples are but what you would like to
do is you would like to use this really
large data set in order to help you with
learning the association between the
data points and the labels so for
example in this case you would have
something like like an image
classification data set and I'm gonna
take the example here of medical data so
you have a pictures of lungs let's draw
a long here that is an ugly long you
have pictures of lungs and whether or
not they are they have like a tumor in
them right so medical data is very hard
to get especially labeled medical data
because you need first of all you need
the data itself but then you also need
like like one at least one but ideally
like three radiologists to look at
whether or not this is a good or a bad
image and label it so it's usually very
expensive to collect that data but you
might have plenty of unlabeled data
right you might just be able to go who
you're through through some database and
find like anonymized undiagnosed long
scans somewhere lying around the same
with image like other images
so labeling images is pretty human
intensive but the internet contains like
a whole bunch of unlabeled images so the
task of semi-supervised learning is how
do you use this unlabeled data set in
order to make your classification on the
label data set easier and fix match
combines two approaches to this in a
smart way namely the consistency and
confidence approach right so what does
what does well it will jump right into
into the method so basically what you
want to do is you want to say my loss
that I optimized right this is my loss
consists of two parts namely a
supervised loss which is your classic
classification loss right plus an
unsupervised loss right and then you
have like some sort of a trade-off
parameter in front now your supervised
loss here this is where this is just the
the cross-entropy
let's call it h between your predicted
labels and your the actual true labels
right and the predicted labels say they
can be you know kind of a distribution
over labels now the magic of course is
here in the unsupervised loss and this
unsupervised loss this is what's
described here in this part right so the
unsupervised loss is going to be this
age between P and Q and we'll see what P
and Q is so if for the unsupervised loss
you two of course want to start with an
unlabeled example then you have the same
sample go into two different pipelines
in the first pipeline up here what you
do is you so-called weekly augmented and
here we're dealing with images so we
have to talk about image augmentation so
image augmentation has long been used in
supervised learning to kind of give you
more it's kind of a cheat to give you
more training data so if you have an
image right of let's say
famous cat you can obtain met more
training data if you for example by
random cropping so you can random crop
let's say we just take this bottom right
corner here and then we enlarge it to
the original size right then it is still
sort of a cat but it's just a part of a
cat right but usually that helps because
you you say okay um my image data set is
just pictures of animals right it's
entirely conceivable that someone held
the camera like this or like this right
so technically in terms of generalizing
to a test set these both data points
should be valid so I'm just gonna add
both to my training data so you can see
how from one training data point you can
get many training data points just by
doing this cropping what you can also do
is you can flip it left right right you
just in swap the pixels left right and
usually the these kind of um so a a a
cat that has a little dark spot here is
still a cat when it has too little dark
spot over there right but to your
classifier those are two different
samples so you can do many of those
things and they have to kind of
augmentations they have what they call
weakly augmented and strongly augmented
right so in the weakly augmented
pipeline I think they just they crop and
they they shift and they rotate or
something like this so you can see here
this this horsey here it is something
like it's cropped here about then it is
turned slightly to the left and then
yeah I think that's it so they crop they
rotate and then they also flip
horizontally at random in like 50
percent of the time so these are what's
called weekly augmented the goal here is
just to kind of obtain a bit more
training data alright so you run this
through your model through your
classification model as you would
a regular sample and you get a
prediction now from your prediction you
can take the highest prediction here and
that is going to be your pseudo label so
this is P of Y this is your distribution
that you estimate right so and this and
this if you just take the max this is
going to be your Y hat right and this is
what they call a pseudo label sorry
you'll see why it is called a pseudo
label so the other pipeline here is the
strong augmentation pipeline now in weak
augmentation we just wanted to get
somewhere training it in strong
augmentation now the goal is to really
screw up that picture to the point where
it's still you know you could recognize
it in the same class but you can see
here the augmentations they go wild so
you play around with the color with the
hue you play around with the light
intensity right with the contrast you
can do many many things you can see this
this image looks basically nothing like
this image buddied you can still kind of
recognize it as a horse but the strongly
augmented data is much more distorted
than the weakly augmented data and
that's the point so also you send the
strongly augmented data through the
model and again you get a prediction
right and now is that the trick is you
take the label from here and you you
take that as if it were the true label
right you take that as if it were the
true label and you form a loss from this
prediction being the model prediction as
if this thing here that also comes from
the model as if that was the true label
right that's why it's called a pseudo
label because it is a label that you
produce from the model itself now of
course if these were to be the same
picture it would be kind of pointless
right that's why you see there
needs to be a weekly and a strongly
augmented pipeline I am pretty sure ammo
if you want a more basic version of this
make this just clean
so no augmentation and make this augment
it right that's that's how you can think
of it the fact that there is weak and
here strong augmentation I think is just
a your classic trick to get more
training data but in essence you can
think of it as this is here the clean
thing you just want to produce a label
and then you want the that an Augmented
version of the image has the same label
now you can think of it shortly what
does this model learn if you just have
this you remember I think the important
thing is always to remember that there
are two components here right there is
first the supervised loss this is the
important one ultimately because we have
the true labels right and then second
there is the unsupervised loss which is
just an auxiliary loss that is supposed
to just kind of tune our model to the
nature of the data right so don't forget
that this this down here just concerns
the unsupervised part of that loss so if
you think what does the model actually
learn when whenever you train it like
this it basically learns to revert this
strong augmentation right say basically
sells hey model whenever I give you a
week
augmented image and I distort it heavily
right whenever I give you an image and
that distort it heavily I want the label
to be the same so the model basically
learns that whatever the image the
whatever the image the model at the end
of the trend will be able to basically
map any strongly augmented picture to
the same class as a weekly augmented
picture if it comes from the same source
right so
the model basically learned to ignore
these kinds of augmentations that's what
this loss over here does it basically
says these sorts of augmentations these
sorts of distortions of images please
ignore those because I always want you
to output the same label here in the
prediction here as if I had not
distorted or just weakly distorted the
image so that's that's what you have to
keep in mind that this this loss is
designed to make the model not
distinguish between differently
augmented versions of the same image and
interestingly that really seems to help
with the with the supervised loss right
my kind of hypothesis is is that all
these methods what they're kind of
trying to do is to just tune the neural
network to the let's say the orders of
magnitude of the of the input data and
also to the kinds of augmentations that
the humans come up with and that's a
very important point
so the Ottoman tations and here we said
you know it's it's kind of a rotation
and the crop the kind of augmentation
really seemed to play a role
so this paper finds that on C 410 where
the state of the art I believe is
something like ninety six ninety seven
percent accuracy on C for ten with just
two hundred and fifty labeled examples
right now the usual data set size is
about fifty thousand it goes to ninety
four point three four point nine percent
so almost 95 percent accuracy with the
state of the art being like ninety seven
this is incredible with just two hundred
and fifty labeled examples crazy right
and it with only four labels per class
it gets eighty eight point six percent
so that's just forty images with labels
they get a
8.6 percent of of the of accuracy
compared to the 97 percent that you get
with like 50,000 images that is pretty
pretty cool right simply by having all
other images not labeled but pseudo
labeled and consistency regularized
right so the the two to two things that
are combined by fixed match again or
consistency regularization which
basically it means that the model should
output similar predictions when fed
perturbed versions of the same image
right this they they're really
forthcoming that they are not the ones
who invented this they just combine the
consistency regularization with the
pseudo labeling now the pseudo labeling
they have also not invented the pseudo
labeling leverages the idea that we
should use the model itself to obtain
artificial labels for unlabeled data
we've seen a lot of papers in the last
few months or years where it's like the
teacher teaches the student and then the
student teaches the teacher model again
and so on so that they simply combine
the two methods in a clever way they
have one last thing that is not in this
drawing namely they only use the pseudo
label they have a break right here and
they only use the pseudo label if if the
confidence if this P of Y here is above
a certain threshold so they don't take
all the pseudo labels but they only take
the labels where the model is fairly
sure about right so they haven't
actually an ablation study where they
show that this is reasonably reasonably
important and if you go down here where
they say ablation or is it ablation
ablation study oh yeah something I also
find cool if you just give one image per
class this one image per class ten
images that are labeled
it still gets like 78 percent accuracy I
think the images are chosen as good
representations of their class but still
one image per class pretty pretty cool
an important part of this is the
ablation study where they say okay we
want to tease apart why this algorithm
why this on semi-supervised learning
technique works so well and they find
several important factors they find for
example that they're all mentation
strategy is extremely important so how
they augment the images is very
important you see here the error of this
4.8% and the 250 label split if you
change up the if you change up the the
augmentation strategies your error gets
higher right and so they say we use this
cutout and we measure the effect of cut
out we find that both cut out and seek T
augment are required to obtain the best
performance removing either results in
in a comparable increase in error rate
we've seen before for example they went
they went from there some 93 sorry 93
point something percent to ninety four
point something percent from the
previous state-of-the-art
semi-supervised learning and here they
find that simply changing the
augmentation strategy changes the error
by more than a percent so you can just
see this in context of of what's
important here right
they say again the ratio of unlabeled
data seems pretty important we observe a
significant decrease in error rates by
losing using a large amounts of
unlabeled data right then the optimizer
and learning
schedule seems to be very important as
well in that they use this they say STD
with momentum works much better than
Adam and then they use this decreasing
learning rate schedule this cosine
learning rate schedule so there seem to
be a lot of things a lot of hyper
parameters that are fairly important
here and you can see that the gains are
substantial sometimes but they aren't
like through the roof substantial where
you can make a good argument that it is
unclear how much really comes from this
clever combination that fit fix match
proposes and how much also just comes
from whether or not you set the hyper
parameters correctly and exactly how
much computation are you able to throw
at selecting your selecting your hyper
parameters so that that seems to be a
bit of a a bit of a pain point for me
they also say we find that tuning the
weight decay is exceptionally important
for low label regimes right choosing a
value that is just one order of
magnitude larger or smaller than optimal
can cost ten percentage points or more
and so that all of that seems to me that
this this kind of research where you're
you're nibbling for half or single
percentage points in accuracy while a
single misstep in a choice of hyper
parameter might cost you ten times that
gain is is a bit sketchy now I recognize
they get numbers like no one else has
gotten before but where exactly the
gains come from and if the gains really
come from this architecture or actually
just more from throwing computer
at it I don't know all right with that I
hope you enjoyed this and I invite you
to check out the paper bye-bye